alright that's done what's next set off
the nuke various emulators are
projecting that hundreds of thousands
will die hey everybody its charlie time
to enter flash time there's a nuke
that's threatening the city and only the
flash family can save it so they finally
confirmed officially that Jay Garrick
and Jesse quick are coming back to the
TV show in episode 15 they gave us a
whole bunch of information about the
episode and they're introducing the
concept of flash time even though we've
already seen versions of it so I'll
explain the difference between what the
TV shows done with it as well as the
difference between that in Hypertime
Hypertime is like a completely different
idea there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so the episode
description reads when a nuclear bomb
detonates in downtown central city Barry
Jesse quick and Jay Garrick slow down
time by entering flash time as everyone
in the city is frozen the three
speedsters push themselves to the
breaking point to save the city and
everyone in it so just to be clear when
it says the entire city is frozen
they're not leaching the kinetic energy
out of the citizens the way that Grodd
does in the comics recently there was a
flash comic book where Grodd tries to
steal the Speed Force from Barry and in
doing so he uses technology to leech the
speed out of everything in the city so
when the flash runs really fast it just
seems like everyone is frozen because
he's moving so fast but then there are
other characters like the turtle that
can literally slow people down by
leaching the kinetic energy out of
things
[Music]
so in this case is just a flash family
moving as super speed for the entire
episode so when I posted that video and
danielle Panabaker was teasing that the
episode would be a concept they'd never
tried before it's literally just an
episode where all the speedsters are
moving at super speed the entire time
because the bomb they say the nuclear
bomb has gone off downtown so you have
to imagine that an explosion goes off
Barry immediately goes into SuperSpeed
and Jay Garrick and Jesse quick just
happened to be there and do the same
thing and then they have to figure out
what to do because it's too late to stop
the bomb from going off whereas last
year they had a gorilla grodd plot that
was almost the same like the clip that I
put at the beginning of this where he
literally just tried every single
combination at SuperSpeed
until he got the right one so in this
case they have to find some other
solution to the problem in their number
of comic book solutions to that problem
but I don't think they're gonna use time
travel like Barry would probably think
about that but then because of what
happened with sabot our last year and
Jay Garrick being so pissed off about
him probably wouldn't let him do that so
the only other ways to stop a blast like
that without having firestorm nearby to
convert that energy into something else
would be to find a way to vent it into
another dimension with Cisco who can't
move at SuperSpeed
even though we saw iris in SuperSpeed
they call flash time with Barry during
episode 10 I'll talk about that in a
second too that's a bit of a different
twist but the only other way to contain
it would be for them to run around the
blast radius so fast that they contain
it into a funnel that just goes up into
the air which is also not that great so
I have a feeling they'll find a way to
port it into a different dimension
because it's not like they're gonna do
the Superman thing where they just fly
around the earth in Reverse time that
would be hilarious if they tried
something like that
[Music]
so it seems more plausible that they
would try to just run around it contain
the blast and then vent it into another
dimension you got to feel bad for
anything that's trying to live on earth
15 they got the dose of radiation that
they vented back during episode 10 and
now it sounds like they might get an
even bigger dose of that but I think a
lot of that just depends on how big the
blast gets before the flash family is
able to get to it you have to imagine
though downtown relatively populated so
if the bomb goes off it sounds like if
the flash is normally a show that does a
lot of big comic book II things and they
try to pull as many ridiculous things
from the movies as possible then let me
know in the comments do you actually
think that they would try that Superman
ending like actually reversing the flow
of time or do you think they'll take the
more realistic route where it's a bigger
blast but you have three flashes running
around to contain it invent it into
another dimension the problem being that
you also have to have a Cisco to open a
portal so they'd have to find a way to
put Cisco into flash time without we're
going to work so there has to be some
workaround for that problem we've had a
lot of theories about iris maybe being
pregnant and that's why she was able to
exist in flash time with Barry these are
some of the examples of Barry being in
flash time
we're moving so quickly that everyone
else is still Paul did you this is me I
actually don't know
[Music]
remember those scenes during season
three when savitur was running berry
through those special Speed Force
tunnels kicking his ass that's also a
slightly different idea from flash time
so it's almost like him jumping from the
Speed Force dimension into our third
dimension then pulling Barry back up
into it running through that then
jumping back out at a different point in
the third dimension in its seeming like
he teleports and moves superfast even
though he was kind of using the Speed
Force as an alternate dimension to fold
space just remember the TV show tends to
introduce really small concepts that it
then turns into really big things later
on so like them taking down the meta
during episode 10 seemed like a pretty
big deal but this is a much much bigger
version of that then in that same
episode you have iris also being able to
exist in flash time with Barry then not
understanding why that being a much
bigger thing probably because of the
twist of episode 16 when we get to see
iris become a speedster but we still
don't have any confirmation about why
she gets those Speed Force powers if it
has to do with people with transferring
Speed Force energy into her because that
is a big comic book concept that they
haven't fully explored on the TV show
without you know just hooking Barry up
to a bunch of machinery like during
season 2 when zoom was trying to steal
his power
[Music]
but in the more recent flash rebirth
comics they've explored the idea of
people taking and giving speed just by
running around people in a special way
you can't actually do it without having
to jack into speedsters with special
machinery I'm still kind of in favor of
the idea of them using this Irish twist
as a way to lead into tornado twins like
her being pregnant and having the
tornado twins and then eventually Bart
Allen because they feels like they're
using all this to build towards
something really awesome that people
have been wanting for a long time and
Bart Allen is just one of those things
so even if we don't get him by next
season even if coffee-shop girl doesn't
end up being a version of that they will
eventually get to a version of Bart
Allen is not a question of if it's just
a question of when as far as I know Jay
Garrick and Jesse quick are only back
for this one episode right now Jesse
quick is with her team on earth - jay
garrick has been on earth three since
the end of season three so I'm assuming
they just go back there at the end of
the episode after they save the day but
just let me know in the comments if
there's any special comic book concepts
that you guys want me to explain
technically it's a new flash power but
is something that we've seen him do on
the show before so it's not that new
it's just him learning to use his
abilities in a slightly different way to
greater effect but flash family writer
died and Wally West is actually supposed
to show up at the end of legends of
tomorrow
episode 11 so that's gonna air on Monday
of course I'll do a video for it so be
sure you watch legends on Monday night
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
that video and of course there's a lot
more Black Panther infinity war stuff
that's going to be posting in the next
couple of days so click here for brand
new flash and click here for all my
Black Panther Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight